et pour commencer cette information
stéphane le foll étaient au palais des
congrès à versailles toute la journée
d'aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'agriculture participer à un séminaire
du réseau rural
2014-2020 thème du débat accompagner les
transitions des territoires ruraux un
séminaire et qui visait à échanger entre
le gouvernement les régions et les
acteurs de l'agriculture et des
territoires ruraux français sur
différents enjeux comme les transports
la santé la rurbanisation et l'énergie
des problématiques en pleine transition
pour le monde agricole je vous propose
d'écouter stéphane le foll
on avait présenté ensemble un appel à
projets et 16 grands projets ont été
retenus c'est quand même près de 23
millions d'euros qui sont investis dans
ce réseau pour justement animer ce monde
rural est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
son intérêt c'est de revenir parce que
depuis le départ j'ai soutenu ce réseau
est lassé de refixer des grands
objectifs